ce drame est ce que vous connaissez
l'histoire du marteau leur flou rené
juste à lui est un jeune abbé de
province sans histoire non mais regardez
moi c'était rare non moi je lui confie
volontiers mes enfants à condition que
ce soit pas les miens c'est le mec qui
est derrière la sur cette image
l'hôte furby c'est son frère valentin
qui a fait plein de trucs pour les
aveugles mais ça c'est une autre
histoire
or donc c'est par accident que ce fieffé
à huy le curé a inventé tout un pan de
la géologie
la légende raconte qu'un jour où ce
qu'ils avaient des moufles à la place
des mains et la tête dans le xi et gore
sa wii a fait tomber par terre un
malheureux cristal de calcite et pas
sous ses yeux globuleux dégoulinante
d'une intelligence féroce ça fait non
pas des chocapics mais des petits
cristaux de calcite de la même forme je
mettrais que le gros de départ des rambo
est à 8 notre honorable ab qui était
aussi géologue ce qui explique pourquoi
il joue avec des cailloux se dit m si je
continue à martyriser ce pauvre cristal
comme moi même je l'étais dans mon
enfance par mes camarades de classe
parce qu'on peut dire j'ai pas vraiment
gagner à la loterie de la vie est ce que
je vais continuer à obtenir des ronds
beau être de plus en plus petits et si
oui quand est-ce que ça s'arrête à
l'échelle de la molécule qui se dit et
qui s'appelle orio la molécule intégrant
enfin maintenant on dit la maille comme
dans un tricot en fait selon phase ii
furby les atomes de notre calcite
s'arrange eux mêmes sous cette même
forme de rango est comme une brique de
lait yop en chine et en combinant ces
briques pencher on obtient notre gros
cristal de départ un peu comme si les
cristaux était du pixel art mais en 3d
du côté du voxel art
oui un pixel en 3d s'appelle un voxel
ici vraiment on se dit verse truies en
diable voilà donc l'hypothèse de notre
père
oui oui oui oui on l'a vérifié il saisit
son marteau de géologues et se met à
dégommer tous les minéraux qui lui passe
sous la main pour voir ce qu'ils ont
dans le ventre
imaginez juste un peu la scène georges
cuvier himself rapporte monsieur à huy
n'hésite pas à mettre en pièces sa
petite collection
ces cristaux ce qu'il obtient de ses
amis ils devaient être contents éclater
sous le marteau
partout il retrouve une structure fondée
sur les mêmes lois du coup gargamel
n'était pas très très apprécié de ses
contemporains c'est étonnant il a même
hérité du surnom de cristal au
classement je sais pas vous moi je
trouve ça un peu classe comme nom de
serial killer de minéraux mois alors
tout ça c'est un peu comme newton et sa
pomme
on sait pas trop ce qui relève de la
réalité et ce qui relève du mythe mais
en tout cas c'est une belle histoire et
ce serait donc en ruinant sa propre
collection et celle de ses rares copains
qui a eu aurait inventé accidentellement
la cristallographie où la science des
cristaux et oui bon alors j'entends déjà
les puristes qui vont crier oulala alors
évidemment c'est pas uniquement grâce
aux productions scientifiques de notre
abbé il yad autres géologues ont permis
de fonder cette discipline misant sur la
science efforts collectifs tout ça comme
le bon rom est de l'île voilà comme ça
c'est dit kevin tu es venger tu peux
retourner manger tes pêche au thon et
alors ce qu'ont découvert notre gang de
cristallographe c'est donc que tous les
minéraux qu'on connaît sont formés de
briques répété à l'envi tel un pavage en
quelque sorte
voilà la somme est les matheux dans la
poche que voulez vous je suis démago oui
à la nature non aux arômes artificiels
et aux gitans
sauf que toutes les briques de départ
n'ont pas toujours la même forme c'est
pas toujours des briques pencher comme
pour laquelle site
et oui aux lego store du géologue on
peut choisir entre cette forme de
briques défini par la longueur des
arêtes et les angles entre les fasse ce
qui nous donne cette système cristal
cubique quadratique hexagonal
romo hedrick ortho rouby kimono
cliniques et précliniques et puis cette
vidéo vous sera aussi utile au scrabble
qui a attisé votre et xénophobie ce qui
veut dire qu'on peut ranger tous les
5600 minéraux ou connaît aujourd'hui
parmi cette forme géométrique chaque
minérale est ensuite obtenu en
retaillant dans ses formes primitives à
lui on a même fait des modèles en bois
de c'est cette forme on peut on observer
dans quelques musées parce qu'il en a
fait d'état notamment au musée de
minéralogie de l'école des mines à paris
que je vous invite vivement à aller
visiter dans le monde d'après parce que
c'est vraiment mes préférés il est dans
son jus avec ses vieilles petite armoire
et tous placés trop cool et vous pourrez
même y voir le bureau de votre marque
leur fout puisque il était le tout
premier conservateur de ce musée entre
autres réalisations voilà il a même sa
statue dans la galerie de minéralogie du
muséum national d'histoire naturelle
oui je suis un petit peu fan je vous
laisse aller les voir sa page wikipédia
ça vous intéresse ou alors si vous êtes
chômeur et que du coup vous n'avez rien
de mieux à faire à part a cité le
système en volant le pain des honnêtes
gens comptent sur vous mais je m'égare
ses sept systèmes cristallin un peu
comme les sept nains mais en plus
géométriques c'est un des critères
essentiels pour reconnaître un minéral
et ça tombe bien parce que figurez vous
que c'est justement l'objet de cette
vidéo et oui ce fut une très très longue
introduction mais ô combien plaisante
imaginez vous faites votre voilà ce que
j'ai dit que je fais des vieux bruits de
bouche dégueulasse votre durée imaginer
ça imaginez vous faites votre promenade
dominicale dans la nature quand soudain
en soulevant une crotte de chien passe
vous découvrez un minéral vous savez pas
ce que c'est mais vous mourrez d'envié
de le savoir eh bien vous êtes au bon
endroit grâce à moi vous allez pouvoir
identifier facilement les minéraux les
plus courants mais en plus vous aurez
perdu un quart d'heure de votre vie
alors déjà qu'est ce donc un minéral me
demandez-vous avidement et bien
cunégonde c'est un solide qui présente
une structure de cristal et une
composition chimique définissent house
house house a pas comme une roche donc
qui elle est un assemblage de minéraux
par exemple le gras ni encore lui
toujours lui est une roche qui contient
les
nero quartz feldspath et mika ces
minéraux la semaine sous forme de grains
ont dit que la roche a une texture grenu
si vous souvenez de la vidéo sur la
bouillabaisse nous ici on va plutôt
s'intéresser aux minéraux mastoc le gens
qu'on trouve dans les musées ou chez les
naturopathes pour soigner la qualité de
votre corps et surtout les paires trophy
de votre porte monnaie a laissé bardi
pour commencer outre la forme du minéral
le premier critère qui vous viendra
spontanément en tête si vous êtes
normalement constitué c'est la couleur
effectivement certains minéraux sont
très identifiables par leur couleur
c'est le cas du soufre natifs qui est
encore plus jeune que le blanchisseur de
lucky luke mais méfiez vous parce que
c'est pas toujours aussi évident
regardez tous ces machins sont une seule
et même espèce minérale de la fluorite
eh oui selon les impuretés qu'elle
contient elle peut être choix incolore
bleues vertes jaunes blanches roses
brune noir violette rouge ou pourpre et
floride c'est la gay pride elle toute
seule
après la couleur la transparence
certains minéraux sont transparents
comme le quartz ou la floride autres
sont translucides comme la gamme et
d'autres complètement opaque comme le
cuivre la pyrite la galène où les
comptes de campagne de françois fillon
même genre toujours on a aussi les
classes est ce que votre minérale va
renvoyer fort la lumière qu'il reçoit
comme un miroir c'est le cas de la
pyrite par exemple on dit que son éclat
et métalliques est-ce qu'il est plutôt
adamantin comme le diamant d'où son nom
est ce que les clubs plutôt vitre comme
le quartz gras comme votre mère ou comme
le talent perlé comme les mika qui sont
même un petit peu et riz descendez fois
ou alors mat comme l'argile et c'est là
qu'on voit que le géologue est un peu
poète aussi au fond bien au fond pour
creuser pardon
humour après il ya aussi la densité en
soupesant votre cailloux à la main et ce
qui vous paraît loulou moins lourd qu'un
caillou standard concile est
particulièrement dense ça peut être de
la galène sinon l'hématite et la pyrite
sont pas mal danse aussi
alors maintenant la trace sa série good
run une feuille blanche et servez vous
de votre minérales comme à crayons oui
vous êtes géologue maintenant vous devez
tout ça avec des claques de quelle
couleur est la trace que votre
échantillon laisse sur le papier vous
pouvez avoir des surprises avec ce test
si on prend deux minéraux noir qui se
ressemblent et qui sont tous les deux
des oxydes de fer l'hématite et la
goethite la première va laisser une
trace rouge sang et la deuxième une
trace jaune ocre donc malgré les
apparences c'est pas les mêmes créés
d'une couleur alors maintenant le
clivage ici on cause pas de décolleté un
milieu pauvre bil'in qui nous regardent
homme-là de fromage c'est la manière
dont minérale se casse
est-ce qu'il se brise selon des plans
préférentielles dans l'espace par
exemple notre calcite elle va se casser
tout net en petit robot être ou bien le
mica il va s'effeuiller comme une
danseuse burlesque on parle de plantes
clivages à ce moment là et si au
contraire il y en a pas de plan de
clivage plus ou moins nettes on parle de
cassure comme la fameuse caisse sur con
côté dale qui va rappeler des souvenirs
aux habitués de la chaîne
regardez bien votre minérale est ce
qu'il a l'air d'avoir pris un pet comme
le cul d'une bouteille en verre ce qui
fait apparaître des espèces de cercles
concentriques oui je les aime beaucoup
ses cercles concentriques et ben ça
c'est une question qu'on coheed c'est un
excellent moyen de reconnaître
l'obsidienne qui est du verre naturel à
l'intérieur ces attentes sont
complètement en vrac ce qui explique que
ça se casse n'importe où n'importe
comment s'en suivent deux plan bien
défini
n'oubliez pas le spectacle de fiona ma
jumelle morte est disponible en replay
dès à présent sur sa chaîne youtube
au programme du rire des larmes et des
propos clivant et toujours sans
concession sur le monde qui nous entoure
[Applaudissements]
maintenant la mcl parfois vous pouvez
voir plusieurs cristaux du même minérale
qui sont enchevêtrées et la manière dont
ils se mélangent c'est ce qu'on appelle
la mcl et ça aussi ça peut nous
renseigner sur le nom du vénérable sus
mentionnés par exemple le gypse peut
avoir plusieurs genres de mac dont une
typique en fer de lance et la star au
tydos y en a plusieurs dont une que je
trouve assez classe c qui s'appelle en
croix de saint-andré voilà de quoi vous
la péter lors des prochains repas de
fête surtout si vous voulez qui se
termine plus alors la suite fait
intervenir un peu chealsea par un
heureux hasard vous vous baladez avec
une fiole d'acide chlorhydrique sur vous
ou au pire un peu de vinaigre blanc ça
tombe bien fait tomber quelques gouttes
sur un coin du minéral un coin que vous
aimez pas trop au cas où
et si sa bulle et sa mousse comme la
bouche d'un épileptique en pleine crise
eureka vous avez trouvé un carbonate
probablement de la calcite notre copine
aubry de planchers du début est dans le
même genre si ça se dissout dans l'eau
ou si c'est une partie de mon lieu sans
live avec le raptor sarde auch egeria ça
peut être du sel
un autre critère essentiel pour
identifier un minéral
oui encore un c'est mieux qu'un
catalogue ikea c'est l'idée c'est la
dureté
résumé des épisodes précédents ah non
pas ces épisodes résumé de mon épisode
précédent sur l'échelle de moss c'est
l'échelle qui nous sert à estimer la
dureté des minéraux c'est à dire la
facilité avec laquelle on peut les
réparent exemple vous pouvez rayer le
talk à l'ongle et si vous prenez un bout
de quartz vous pourrez rayer un verre
avec plutôt que de ruiner votre propre
vaissellerie allait plutôt emprunté le
vert de quelqu'un d'autre fait comme à
lui faites vous des amis
et si vous avez un diamant sous la main
vous pourrez y est absolument tout et
n'importe quoi avec c'est même le seul
intérêt voire un diable mais attention
ça veut pas dire pour autant que le
diamant est incassable tel un bape tout
il est fragile ne vous amusez pas à
jouer en marteleur fou avec la bague
dire grand mère tu que oui à ce moment
là où vous allez la brise et son super
pouvoir c'est juste qu'on peut pas le
rayer sauf avec un oubli mais on peut
très bien le cas c'est en mille morceaux
ça ça n'a rien à voir par contre si vous
le cas c'est là vous obtiendrez plein de
petits cubes de diamants et d'autres
petits cubes après jusqu'à la molécule
intégrante elle-même cubique merci à 8
maintenant même si c'est un peu plus
anecdotique
l'odeur et le goût vous vous souvenez du
soufre natif dont on a parlé au début et
qui est aussi jaune que tout le casting
des simpson réunis eh bien figurez-vous
qu'il a une délicieuse odeur très
caractéristique d'oeuf pourri la pyrite
aussi vu que elle contient aussi du sou
et si vous êtes d'humeur aventurière ou
si vous avez
bonne assurance vie vous pouvez essayer
de lâcher votre cailloux si ça goûte le
sel basse et que c'en est sis à un vieux
goût salé amer franchement dégueulasse
félicitations vous avez trouvé de la cl
vite je reprécise au passage même si
c'est plus développé dans cette vidéo là
qu'il faut éviter de lécher tout et
n'importe quoi parce que certains
cailloux sont toxiques bien sûr en plus
vous savez pas quel pango un appui se
soulager dessus avant votre passage vous
voudriez pas faire les gros titres comme
étant le géologue amateur qui a fait
émerger une nouvelle pandémie
merci pour nommer mais voilà donc pour
les principaux critères d'identification
des minéraux il y en a beaucoup mais je
vous rassure il y en a encore d'autres
certains minéraux sur une phosphorescent
d'autres sont fluorescent sous une
lumière noire vous pouvez emmener votre
collection avec vous en discothèque si
vous voulez vérifier d'autres encore
sont magnétiques comme suspense
l'allemagne et d'autres encore sont
radioactifs comme la pêche ou l'inde où
mon chouchou le zéro donc vous pouvez
toujours dégainez votre compteur geiger
ya un autre truc très utile et je finis
relations sont n'a pas parlé encore
c'est tout simplement l'endroit d'où
vient votre cailloux si vous avez la
chance de connaître sa provenance ou si
vous l'avez vous-même cueilli de
vaublanc chemin vous pourrez regarder le
genre de cailloux qu'on trouve dans
cette région là vous prenez une carte
géologique ou vous allez sur le site
géoportail est comme ça vous pouvez
aller regarder et ça aide énormément à
réduire le champ de recherche donc
croyez moi c'est une bonne idée et c'est
pas de la triche
voilà donc pour les critères principaux
ça al'air beaucoup comme ça et il ya
plein de mots barbares qui vous sont
tombés dessus d'un coup mais
rassurez-vous le plus dur est passé
maintenant que vous connaissez les
règles du jeu vous allez pouvoir jouer
vous même c'est vraiment plus facile et
amusant à faire que ça en a l'air
sachez que vous n'êtes pas seul dans ce
grand jeu des cailloux il existe plein
de ressources en ligne et des bouquins
pour vous aider et toute une communauté
indique tout ça en description de la
vidéo où vous l'aurez peut-être remarqué
ce que je vous ai présenté là c'est un
peu à la va comme je te pousse c'est mon
soupèse on renifle on taton rayon lait
chemin c'est un peu artisanal tous et je
commence à comprendre la réputation des
jeunes c'est pas notre faute si on
utilise tous nos sens et si on ouvre
tous nos chakras mais les vraies
prouesses qu'ils font aussi comme ça ils
ont à peu près les mêmes critères que
nous densité dureté éclat système
cristallin tous ces trucs là mais ils
ont aussi des outils plus performants et
ils font d'autres mesures à côté dans
des machines et au microscope comme des
mesures de plaies au cros isme dan
isotropique et de bi réflectance c'est
vous qui avez demandé tout ça ça permet
aux minéralogiste d'aller encore plus
loin dans l'identification de leurs
cailloux mais globalement le principal
et chemin faisant les chercheurs
découvrent parfois des nouveaux minéraux
grâce aux progrès techniques on en
découvre même de plus en plus on a
trouvé 150 nouveaux minéraux en 2018
contre une vingtaine dans les années 60
car voyez-vous bien de ces les machines
de plus en plus performantes permettre
de repérer même des minuscules minéraux
microscopique en inclusion à l'intérieur
d'autres minéraux plus grosse et ses
1000 réceptions et du coup il n'y a pas
besoin d'aller à l'autre bout du monde
pour trouver d espèce minérale il suffit
parfois juste d'ouvrir les tiroirs des
collections des facs ou des musées et
les analyser pour décrocher le jackpot
sais c'est un peu génial en fait ils
étaient sous notre nez depuis le début
mais on n'avait juste pas les bonnes
lunettes pour les voir en un mot comme
en cent remugles
or donc vous l'aurez compris la corée du
nord n'est pas le régime le plus et
aussi les jo diversité se porte comme un
charme
8 on dit géodiversité et oui je dis
encore se porter comme un charme et donc
je trouve ça plus réjouissant veux
parler de géodiversité que de
biodiversité en ce moment parce que un
c'est sur yann arthus bertrand et 2 ça
change un peu de découvrir de nouvelles
espèces minérale plutôt que d'en faire
disparaître en mangeant du nutella en
faisant des rondes au volant de notre
humeur
et en plus si jamais vous trouvez vous
un nouveau minéral et qu'il est reconnu
par la commission internationale qui
s'en occupe oui ça aussi ça existe vous
pourrez en gros lui donner le nom de
votre choix à condition qu'il soit dispo
bien sûr que soient pas offensant et l'
usage veut qu'on termine le nom par it
it est alors comment vous appelleriez
votre minérale à vous quelles seraient
ses caractéristiques dix mois tout ça en
commentaire c'est pour moi référencement
maintenant vous savez tout bon jeu à
vous voilà on fera peut-être quelques
lives twitch d'identification de
minéraux ça pourrait être marrant dit
moi si ça vous même si vous allez très
vite comprendre que je suis à peu près
aussi mauvaise
à ce jeu qui a imité céline dion je vous
ai compris
je ne l'est pas quand merci au type
heures dont l'éclat adamantin m'éblouit
jour après jour c'est grâce à votre
soutien que tout ceci est
[Musique]
pour